[Musique]
merci Kim pour ton petit message de
remerciements
c'est autre chose c'est Kim Kardashian
qui était au Parc des Princes et je peux
vous dire j'ai fait des pieds et des
mains vous parlez sur WhatsApp la
jeunesse de l'histoire elle vous appelle
elle commence à
elle me laisse un message
[Rires]
d'accord
d'anglais on est en train de trois
petits non mais je vous dis que je
prends des cours d'anglais ce que ça
donne pour l'instant on sait que ça
donne on va voir
même comme ça
tout le monde a mon numéro tous les gens
un peu important
c'est vrai déjà quelque part
de trois étapes
de production donc je suis actionnaire
et ah bah oui
bien sûr et ça fait partie de mon groupe
de production kim Kardashian voix elle
dit ça va Hanouna ça va je suis pas
content de ton travail on va se voir 2
minutes
[Rires]
vrai ou pas
un jour elle dit bon je veux rencontrer
les actionnaires
il m'appelle
kim Kardashian elle veut nous voir
si la vérité frère déjà
normalement là je peux pas je peux pas
sur ma vie
qu'est-ce qui se passe et tout je dis je
suis en train de faire je prépare ça si
je prépare et Pessac c'est bien cool
absolument elle dit elle veut tous les
actionnaires elle veut nous rencontrer
tout ça bon je vais là-bas j'arrive à
Kim Kardashian elle est avec genre son
manager tu vois j'aurais deux trois
personnes je connais pas tu vois des
Américains
[Rires]
genre
business ou je sais pas quoi exécutive
et voilà meuf elle dit mon celui-là la
vérité Dieu bénisse et bien il est bien
il revient et c'est tout de suite
comment je suis frère mine de rien dans
l'organigramme oh frère juste votre
escort ce jour-là c'était comment ah oui
pantalon jacquard
[Rires]
je suis arrivé donc elle dit on est
comme ça en train de travailler et on
donne des idées tous en anglais tu vois
sur des programmes tout ça on est une
dizaine tout ça les trois quatre
actionnaires plus ou le stade de Kim
Kardashian et Kim Kardashian moi je
commence à dire yes I like very much
je TV
et là le gars il lui dit un Américain
sur la tête de ma mère il est tunisien
regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait chier là
Israël il a raison il a raison
et un moment moi j'ai un ministre aussi
il est dans les macarons ah oui des
macarons à tout le monde et je vois kim
Kardashian frère je la vois elle vole
des macarons
sur
la joie kim Kardashian
[Rires]
et elle voit que je la vois elle voit
que je la vois elle m'attrape comme ça
elle me fait comme ça on passe comme as
et elle passe
[Musique]
[Rires]
comme ça kim Kardashian problème
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on se laisse le soir
je suis chez moi mon frère
WhatsApp je vois là
si elle veut celle-là
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu as dit à quelqu'un qui
avait j'avais volé des macarons
la vérité sur ma vie je suis pas dans
ses délires
que j'ai pris des macarons
je lui dis moi si tu veux à la maison je
dis j'ai des briques à l'oeuf n'importe
quoi
une Fiat Punto
[Rires]
mes frères je vois kim Kardashian
elle tire comme un
œuf
à la maison on a mangé des briques
sur ma vie on partage des briques à
l’œuvre je dis t'inquiète pas on parle
plus des sous cette histoire de macaron
et de fil en aiguille elle me dit
qu'est-ce que tu fais je lui dis moi là
moi je suis pas con avec des gens
n'hésitez pas à quoi que le PSG tu vois
bien sûr que je suis pas contre le PSG
tu peux avoir des places je dis pas
cette année l'année prochaine il y a PSG
Rennes
[Applaudissements]
et depuis on est un peu pimpots
je te dis voilà je te dis la vérité qui
est dès qu'elle a des macarons le parent
elle part en cacahuète c'est à dire que
son voile aurait été en virage avec les
ultra bien sûr bien sûr je lui ai eu des
places il y a un an et pas pour le
Bayern c'était pour Rennes qu'il fallait
elle voulait dire
PSG Rennes voilà et vous n'êtes pas allé
avec elle au match
et moi je suis son trompette
[Musique]
[Rires]
avec Kardashian
ils sont gonfle j'étais tranquillement
j'étais j'étais en train de faire un
bowling quoi
c'est pas votre délire du tout non pas
du tout ah non pas du tout
vous aviez beaucoup aimé quand tu avais
fait la couverture d'un magazine où elle
était avec le vert sur ses fesses